centre-ville, puis vous allez
voir, ça fonctionne.
Mathieu Prost.
- Des interventions policières
remplacées par des interventions
sociales. Ce ne sont pas desent
de la police qui le proposent;
c'est ce sur quoi
le ministère de
la Sécurité publique.
GENEVIÈVE GUILBAULT, ministrec
- Environ 30 % des appels au 911
ici, à Montréal, sont des appels
liés à la santé mentale.
Des appels, des situations
qui deviennent des problèmes
nt un peu sur les bras
de nos policiers, mais qui
ne sont ne sont ne sont pas dess
de sécurité publique.
- Cette unité d'intervenants
les policiers, existe déjà
depuis un an à Montréal.
- Ça va bien, Monsieur?
- Un projet pilote dansi serai a
étendu à toute la métropole
grâce à 25 millions de dollars
de Québec et autant de Montréal.
deux patrouilles de l'EMMIS,
l'équipe mobile de médiation
et d'intervention sociale.
médiation en intervention socia
- Présentement, on est à l
voyageur, on est juste à côté
de la station Berri-UQAM, aux
en fait. Donc, c'est un secteur,
évidemment, où icoup
d'activité, il y a beaucoup
de mouvements, des va-et-vient.
d'itinérance que de personnes
vulnérables.
- Après moins de 10 minutes
et Camille...
(alarme)
- EMMIS, bonjour!
de l'arrondissement Ville-Marie,
ça va bien?
- Le duo d'intervenants
va répondre aux inquiétudes
à la vente de drogue.
- On a fait... on
appels, beaucoup d'appels quand
il y avait des indésirables
- Qu'est-ce qu'on va faire,
nous, évidemment, on va inclure
ce secteur à nos patrouilles.
- Le concierge à côté s'est
piqué dengues, il s'est
retrouvé à l'hôpital.
- On va être là pour aller
vérifier s'il y a des seringues,
mais nouon va se mettre en contt
avec les travailleurs de rue
du secteur.
- Réaction du citoyen
par des intervenants plutôt
que des policiers :
- Plus il y a de gens concernés,
plus de gens qui nous entendent,
solutionner le problème.
- Ça va permetticiers
de se décharger d'un travail
qui n'est pas nécele leur, qui s
difficil policiers policiers pos
d'aller mobiliser les équipes,
les serv
mises à leur disposition. Nous,
on a dess avec tout
ce qui est... le communautaire.
- Kelly
se démènent pour venir
à une famille de Turcs
signalés à la gare Windsor.
Équipe mobile de médiation
- Donc, ce qu'on essaye
de trouver en ce moment,
c'est des vêtements et des
couvertures pour cette famille
et surtout pour les enfants.
- Bien oui, bien o
je comprends, c'est
bien correct.
- Ce qui s'ajoute à leur début
de soirée : accompagner un jeune
toxicomae injectioe injectioe in
supervisée.
Pendant que Lucie cherche
un transport pour un autre
homme dans le besoin, Kelly
la raison la raison la raison e
leur passager à consommer.
- Il serait nécessaire
de l'accompagner
au refuge Guy-Favreau.
un cancer de quoi?
- De l'oesophage.
- OK.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Le temps, c'est ce luxe
qui manque aux policiers
et qui donne tout son sens
à cette nouvelle équipe.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Les deux intervenantes
ne laisseront pas leur usager
seul très longtemps.
Elles auront juste le temps
de s'occuper du ma
pour la famille turque.
- C'est parce que notre petit
loup, là, à Cactus, lui,
ça prend juste 45 minutes,
son inje
ALAIN VAILLANCOURT, responsable
de la sécurité Ville de Montréal
- Présentement, une policière,
par exemple, va prendre
ganisée,
va l'amener à l'urgence de
l'hôpital, va la laisser là,
va quitter, doit allait vers
d'autres appels. La personne vae
quelques heures plus tard.
- Bonne nouvelle pour les Turcs,
quelques instants plus tard,
un organisme pour réfugiésleur .
- Finalement, Praida les a
acceptés. Fait qu'ils ont
une place où coucher.
- Des réfugiés, des itinérants,
des femmes battues.
KELLY, intervenante psychosoc.
Équipe mobile de médiation
- C'est tout le monde.
En ce moment, on patche
plein de trous. On a un appel.
(rires)
- Depuis un an, l'EMMIS
a géré une moyenne de
15 situations par jour.
La moitié des appels provenaient
d'organismes communautaires
et un tiers du SPVM.
Mais une répartition directe
par le 911 est à
Et il y a aussi des
interventions spontanées.
- Je sens la faim un peu.
- Qu'estnd
tu dis ça? Qu'est-ce que...
- Tu as faim, tu veux...
tu as besoin... tu veux
te cherc
- Je peux-tu rester
avec vous autres?
CAMILLE, intervenante psychosoc.
Équipe mobile d
- Bien, on va...
on va attendre avec toi, là,
jusqu'à ce qu'ils arrivent...
On était au bon lieu
au bon moment, parce que
cette pe
il s'averait qu'elle avait
vraiment besoin d'aide, puis
juste une petite interaction,
puis là, la personne
s'est ouverte.
ent,
EMMIS devrait compter
une cinquantaine d'intervenants,
contre une dizaine aujourd'hui.
Ils seront disponibles 24 heures
sur 24, 7 jours sur 7.Et les int
pas nécessairement les mêmes sur
tout le territoire montréalais.
- Il faut vraiment s'assurer
que ça va prendre, je dirais,
la couleur de l'arrondissement
ou de l'environnement.
Par exemple, on peut penser,
si ça va à... je sais pas,
Montréal-Nord, ça peut être
des incivilités dans le parc
avec les jeunes.
- Mais avec un seul souci
en tête pour celles et ceux
qui arpentent les rues...
- J'ai l'impression que...
t'sais, on fait un petit
changement dans la vie den, puie
c'est ça, la valeur ajoutée,
pour moi.
- Ça roule, Castor!oin de toi, .
- Ici Mathieu Prost,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.